martin biron michel david de luc
ferrandez bonsoir à vous trois mâts la
cpi un fan aussi officiellement le
ministre des transports du québec
françois bonnardel qui a dévoilé
aujourd'hui la dernière mouture de ce
troisième lien entre québec et lévis
projet on en a parlé en début d'émission
plus modeste que l'original donc plus
petits moins cher on va écouter d'abord
le ministre bonnardel
l'objectif principal avec la livraison
du réseau express de capital et une âme
québec lévis c'est de répondre à trop
ressources augmenter l'attractivité du
transport collectif donne une option
additionnelle pour le transport de
marchandises améliorer la fluidité et
assurer la sécurité du réseau ça veut
dire qu aujourd'hui la mise à jour nous
amène à vous dévoiler un projet révisé
un projet estimé à 6.5 milliards de
dollars
merci je vais commencer avec vous est ce
que ce projet révisé de troisième bien à
québec ça répond vraiment aux besoins de
la population
ben je pense que l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui c'était de rendre ce
projet-là plus vendable en campagne
électorale
on aura noté ben oui c'est plus petit
que ce qu'ils avaient sur la table à
vendre c'est sûr qu'un seul tunnel qui
nécessitent le plus gros est lié au
monde de méfaits des mesures est alors
oui on leur dit on l'a même comparé au
tunnel louis-hippolyte-lafontaine alors
dans ce sens le oui est un peu plus
petit et quand même 6 milliards une 1000
$ c'est quand même pas mal d'argent mais
c'est plus pour être capable de le
vendre en campagne électorale
qui s'en vient dans six mois et
d'ailleurs on a noté qu'il y avait un
gros volet pédagogique l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui où on nous a dit écoutez
les délais liés pour rentrer à québec
sont achalandés ils sont vieux notez
qu'il ya 18 liés pour rentrer à montréal
notez qu'il ya cinq ligués pour allier à
ottawa et qui en a un sixième dans les
cartons alors qu'à québec il n'y a que
deux liens qui sont côte à côte alors ça
en prendre à un autre
il en demeure pas moins que ce type de
projet là ils sont tellement gros qu'ils
sont difficiles à faire atterrir et on
le vit aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le maire
de québec et est plus ambivalent existe
un projet qui reste à définir et c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'on a peu de détails
d'un projet là un peu tout le monde ne
rame pas dans le même sens alors ça
c'est la situation actuelle et puis
c'est vrai qu'on avait pas beaucoup de
détails concernant le futur troisième
lien aucun schéma il ya bien une photo
un dessin mais pas d'animation en 3d pas
vraiment de clarifications sur le tracé
précis on parle de dossiers d'affaires
michel qui va être présenté en 2025
alors qu'il devait y avoir une première
pelletée de terre avant l'automne qui
vient qu'est ce que vous en pensez oui
bon on a pas d'étude écouter on en a pas
plus aujourd'hui qu'on en avait la seule
étude que monsieur bonnardel a brandi
c'est toujours la même celle de monsieur
mascotte le qui est professeur à
polytechnique et qui date de 2005 et qui
de toute manière abouti à la conclusion
que s'il valait mieux avoir un
fonctionnel alors le projet parlais
tantôt de la dernière mouture je pense
la dernière avant la prochaine je suis
pas convaincu du tout que ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui vous être ce qu'on va voir
après la prochaine élection parce que
les problèmes de fond demeurent qui est
un problème d'accessibilité à québec et
qui file à un troisième bien oui c'est
fort possible mais pourquoi un tunnel
plutôt qu'un pont passe les bras d'un du
tunnel là je comprends que les voitures
vont passer dans deux tunnels plutôt que
dans 1 mais sachant gérer à l'étalement
urbain le problème demeure entier
quant aux coûts et écouter le sait 6.5
milliards maintenant on verra dans dix
ans qu'elle soit la facture alors moi je
pense que le débat ne change pas de deux
paramètres avec est ce que monsieur
bonnardel a nous a présenté aujourd'hui
concernant le coup monsieur massicotte
l'ingénieur nous disait d'entrée de jeu
là que à son avis c'est un prix plancher
que ça va nécessairement être plus que
ça luc ferrandez est-ce que vous avez
compris les explications qui ont été
données par le ministre pour avoir
enlevé le volet de transport collectif
dans le dans le tunnel on y va vraiment
maintenant avec des voies réservées
seulement en heure de pointe
ça c'est ridicule c'est absolument c'est
une méthode qui était utilisé depuis des
décennies mais ça s'appelle pas de
transport structurants ce rapport
structure est transport en site propre
on fait des voies réservées quand on a
de la congestion des voix de ray des
voies réservées le matin qu'on enlève en
après midi ça c'est quand tu es de la
congestion alors le matin pour éviter la
congestion on fait une voie réservée
pour autobus il reste la journée on
l'enlève est ce qu'on est en train de
nous dire qu'il va y avoir de la
congestion dans le tunnel est ce que
c'est ça le message de monsieur
bonnardel c'est ridicule il n'ya pas
étudié son dossier
et l'autre chat aussi ont cette histoire
de voies réservées qu'on peut mettre mon
avis c'est un trait de peinture c'est un
trait de peinture alors est-ce que tout
à coup à ottawa va se dit oh c'est un
projet de transport en commun parce
qu'un trait de peinture vite que je
devienne le financer à mon avis ils sont
ils il arrive pourra convaincre les
experts est-ce qu'il arrive à convaincre
la population est-ce que ça va lui
permettre de de rechercher un peu
d'adhésion avant l'élection j'en sais
rien mais au niveau des experts c'est
pas pour avec cette importance à la
question du financement d'ottawa parce
que martin le fédéral a accepté de payer
la partie transport collectif en tous
cotisés nous on serait plus ouvert si un
transport collectif sur ce troisième
gain à financer le québec revient avec
cette mouture avec seulement des voies
réservées en heure de pointe en dix ans
on compte toujours sur le financement de
40 % de la part d'ottawa ouais mais
c'est pour l'instant la hippie le projet
là quand on écoute mais le ministre
bonnardel il va être prêt en 2025 alors
en 2025 c'est à ce moment là qu'on va
être capable de déposer le projet est de
voir si le financement est là bon les
politiciens peuvent aussi réussir quand
ils le veulent la faire entrer un cercle
dans un carré alors on verra rendu là
mais mon épaule puis juste régler
l'enjeu au québec ça va déjà être
quelque chose parce que bon je parlais
de monsieur monsieur marchand tente en
tout du goût du maire de québec met you
éric duhaime ou s'il dans l'équation
s'il faisait élire de trois séquences de
trois députés dans les régions de québec
aurait t'il son mot à dire lui va avoir
un pont
dans l'est alors le projet il fait pas
l'unanimité là c'est pas tout le monde
qui vont ensemble dans le même sens et
ça ça fait défaut il va falloir que les
gens s'entendent avant d'avoir un projet
prêt lettre déposée à les financiers et
le vice-premier ministre geneviève
guilbault là tu disais c'est pas mal
unanime l'appui qu'on a concernant notre
projet hormis quelques exceptions près
on pense peut-être au maire de québec
qui n'est toujours pas convaincu du bien
fondé du projet d'ailleurs on va
l'écouter suivi de jeux vidéo
c'est tellement important d'avoir cette
vision là ne plus développer les les
projets de transport pour une ville pour
un secteur pour un groupe avoir vraiment
une très très grande vision inclusive
pour ne pas m'attacher à un arbre ou à
quelconque espace ou mobilier urbain pas
que ça se réalise maintenant la ville a
une influence la ville a une capacité de
faire des études démontrent ici à des
enjeux c'est des problèmes qu'est-ce
qu'on peut y faire comme on peut les
contourner mais avant d'arriver là notre
objectif c'est d'avoir plus de donner
plus de fait plus de démonstration
michel qu'est ce qu'il faut penser de
cette relation entre le maire de québec
et la ministre et guilbaut
battue c'est l'un déjà revu et écoutez
je me souviens quand monsieur monsieur
marchand était élu madame guilbeault
était était extatique elsa enfin et dans
le fond était contente de se débarrasser
de monsieur lavaud mais sa peau était là
on l'a vu avec le tramway que dans le
fond le rapport de force entre la ville
et où les tensions le vrai dire entre la
ville et le gouvernement sont
sensiblement les mêmes qu'elles étaient
avant
hélas quand madame lille body à peu près
tout le monde est d'accord un instant
monsieur marchand est pas tout seul à
pas être d'accord avec ce projet là vous
avez à québec c'est pas aussi avantageux
que ça cette troisième place est
excellent on comprend très bien que les
gens de la rive-sud donc tout avantage à
ça mais qui est parce que dans le fond
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire là
c'est un tunnel qui va relier deux
autoroutes faut pour les gens de québec
je parle de québec ne se parle pas des
banlieues éloignées via sais pas si
intéressant que ça à six mois des
élections est ce que le gouvernement
legault peut vraiment se permettre
d'avoir des relations tendues avec le
maire de québec
eh bien oui malheureusement
il a démontré que lors de la partielle
de marie-victorin qu'il était en état de
grâce c'est à dire que y'a rien qui
l'atteint en ce moment est ce que ça va
changer dans les six prochains mois ce
qu'un dossier majeur arrivé il ya eu des
dossiers majeurs qui se sont produits
deux dans les dernières semaines ça ne
l'a pas touché on a vu avec la pandémie
et le rapport héran etc mais ça ne l'a
pas touché il est en état de grâce
maintenant le troisième mien c'est le
genre de projet qui se fait sur demande
être en opposition avec le maire de
québec et avec l'ensemble des
expériences
c'est sûr que monsieur marchand aussi
des intérêts là bien s'entend aussi avec
le gouvernement de la cac qui y tient à
son tramway a été assez difficile avec
son propre caucus le caucus kaki cela il
y avait des divisions importantes on
parlait de geneviève guilbaud le milieu
éric caire dans l'équation hier jonathan
julien que joue un rôle c'était
difficile et je m'immisce bonnardel à 17
premier ministre a tranché et vieilles a
dit au caucus à québec le député haut
niveau avec le tramway alors s'il vous
plaît pourriez vous garder la paix pour
un moment alors monsieur marchand il
offre son tramway eu le feu vert pour
les appels d'offres alors il ya quand
même intérêt à ce que ça se passe bien
avec le gouvernement la caq je parlais
d'éric duhaime là quand même y guy dans
l'équation au moment où on se parle
alors il va avoir une suite et
d'ailleurs il fait attention monsieur
marchand pour pas pour pas se prononcer
sur le troisième est aujourd'hui et ne
pas non plus le bi fait le lit
l'appareil a pas dit quelle horreur il
ya je dis bah ça répond pas à mes amis
objectif d'étalement urbain mais il
reste à définir alors bien sûr des yeux
un peu lent sa réaction effectivement on
va parler de pandémie maintenant le
ministre de la santé christian dubé qui
qui est sorti aujourd'hui pour parler de
la coved 19 pour rappeler les mises en
garde à l'aube de ce long week-end de
pâques commencé en parlant d urgence les
oppositions aussi on réagit on va
écouter quelques extraits il ya un appel
à la plus grande prudence qui a été
lancée hier on pense que c'est
évidemment la bonne chose à faire puis
écoutons la santé publique où est-il
pour encourager la population du québec
à dire baissez pas les bras moi c'est
mon sentiment c'est que ça me donne le
sentiment que lui a baissé les bras le
gouvernement justement ne veut pas
imposer de règles parce que c'est
impopulaire il est allé d'un bout du
spectre où il contrôler nos vies à
l'autre bout du spectre ou c'est le
laisser faire le plus complètes sont un
peu difficiles à suivre la position d'un
côté pendant le dernier bout de la
pandémie nous disait que la santé
publique devait être indépendante puis
pas d'avoir des influences politiques
vous avez remarqué que depuis quelques
mois la santé publique prend les points
de presse seuls et nous font des
recommandations
alors il faut qu'il se décide
martin il faut penser quoi de tout ça
est ce que le gouvernement a lâché un
peu cette gestion de la pandémie ben non
parce que c'est le gouvernement que le
dernier mot la ccc le gouvernement qui
tranche et qui est prend les décisions
mais il ya définitivement aucun appétit
au gouvernement pour imposer de
nouvelles mesures sanitaires ont été
marqués je pense au gouvernement de la
cac avec le couvre-feu est la langue du
31 décembre
on voit bien aussi ce qui se passe
ailleurs et on réalise que bon on écoute
et on est rendu à la sixième vague en
deux ça fait trois vagues par année
alors est-ce que le gouvernement va
constamment venir dit vous pouvez pas
recevoir plus que six personnes chez
vous de personnes alors un moment donné
et et l'autre l'autre facteur important
là c'est que la plupart des gens sont
vaccinés deux à trois doses alors le
danger d'hospitalisation est moins élevé
alors effectivement un moment donné tu
dis mais apprenez à vivre avec le virus
on envoie quelques consignes ici là mais
c'est sûr qu'il ya un test le test de
pâques parce que les hospitalisations
augmente le personnel de la santé est
passablement infectés alors on envoyait
les messages en conséquence est ce qu'on
est vraiment une santé publique
indépendante
michel on entendu donc le ministre à
dire vous vouliez une gestion
indépendante vous l'avez est ce que
c'est vraiment cas où on a seulement des
conférences de presse séparées d'abord
le directeur national est toujours un
sous-ministre hiérarchiquement il dépend
toujours du ministre de la santé mais il
c'est certain que en dissociant les deux
pas voir le directeur de la santé
publique aux côtés du ministre ou du
premier ministre joue ça donne une
impression d'indépendance et mais il ya
des limites le ca veut pas dire qu'il
faut qu on abandonne le directeur de la
santé publique tout seul devant la
population parce que ce qu'on a ce qu'on
voit maintenant c'est que monsieur
boileau docteur baudot on doit
régulièrement répété ses conseils m'ont
voyait plus le gouvernement on avait
l'impression que le gouvernement s'en
lavait les mains hafidi semaine depuis
des semaines et je comprends que c'est
impopulaire avec le gouvernement voulait
donner l'impression que bon il y avait
compris le message de la population
mais à un moment donné la responsabilité
du gouvernement sans revenir à des
mesures c'est de répéter le message à
l'écouté c'est pas fini cette affaire-là
alors quand le 1er mai ne vient vous
dire que ce pas plus grave qu'un rhume
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que la
population comprenne je comprends que ça
a été un peu sisters contexte mais vous
savez quand on est un peu un minimum de
communication mais pas qu'au vu des
rhumes dans la même phrase est le
premier ministre je pense qu'ils ont mal
géré cette intervention là et les gens
ont compris c'est fini on fait ce qu'on
veut
c'est pas c'est pas la faute de la santé
publique ça moi je pense que monsieur
bois d'auch où il continua à prodiguer
ses conseils on voit que des fois il y
aura le goût de dire écoutez comme le
masque il est clair que dans son esprit
il faut il faut absolument pour allonger
le match mais il va demain le site
gouvernement prendre officiellement la
décision wifi au docteur boileau faire
ses recommandations possiblement dans
les prochaines journées oui bah je pense
que tout le monde a compris que le
masque on voit le garder pour un petit
moment clairement et les qu'est ce que
vous pensez de tout ça mais ce pas une
mauvaise idée qu'on regarde le mètre
minimum en ontario il aurait tiré
plusieurs semaines passant de wilko par
joe et la direction de la santé publique
de l'ontario recommande fortement de
réimposer le masque alors s'il ya deux
mesures qui fort dans ses habitudes
cette capacité de vivre avec le virus
parce que c'est le rhône il qu'à passer
de vie avec le virus et le masque et la
vaccination est la quatrième dose pas
tout de suite mais certainement à
l'automne au tout de suite en ce moment
il ya peu sans doute pas grand chose à
faire on est quand même à 2000 cas dans
les hôpitaux on est beaucoup plus haut
dans la pandémie aujourd'hui qu'on
l'était apathie dernier mais en sûrs à
la sixième vague ont commencé à
descendre et quand ça se passe en europe
ainsi que ça va se passer ici par
ailleurs on se dirige vers l'été alors
proposé de confinement des des grandes
manoeuvres nationale ça fonctionnera pas
mais préparons-nous par l'automne et 4
martine michel disait il faut que
monsieur bouallou et +22 de prise de
poids ben c'est pour l'automne pour cet
automne il va vraiment falloir sur
décide d'aller avec la quatrième dose
que tout le gouvernement mettre son
poids derrière plus de ballons ou quoi
bon bien parfait vous amener à l'automne
luc justement course à la direction du
parti conservateur le choix du prochain
chef vostfr en septembre mais un sondage
léger le coeur révélé que c'est
difficile pour jean charest fasse a
appuyé un poilievre on peut regarder ce
résultat qui nous démontrons dans
l'ensemble des répondants puis un poil
hier jean charest s'est assis au coude à
coude mais quand on regarde chez les
conservateur pierre poilievre est loin
devant en quelques secondes chacun 20
secondes l'udc qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que c'est encore possible
pour jean charest
mais je pense que non même si le mode
électoral au sein du parti conservateur
vol les dix parce que les api de
pallières va surtout dans l'ouest jean
charest va essayer d'aller chercher dans
les maritimes ap alors britannique au
québec et en ontario c'est sa seule
façon de s'en sortir michel oui il va
écouter moi je le problème de monsieur
de monsieur charest ses claques à des
militants conservateurs la majorité sont
avec monsieur poilievre la seule la
seule raison pour laquelle ils auraient
pu être tentés de choisir monsieur
charest sait qu'il aurait été mieux en
mesure de battre les libéraux or une
autre données du sondage montre que non
c'est pas du coq monsieur poilievre
perdrait peut-être face aux libéraux
mais monsieur charest ferait encore
moins bien alors là ils y ont plus le
problème de choix entre le coeur et la
raison ils peuvent se dire que les deux
militent en faveur de monsieur poilievre
et martin dans quelques secondes en
quelques secondes je vous dirais qu'il
faut attendre les débauches marque là ça
va jouer mais je pense que l'udc a
raison les maritimes et le québec c'est
quand même le deux tiers des
circonscriptions au pays alors ça me
jouer beaucoup là alors la clé pour
monsieur charest pour me supplier vous
si mais c'est vraiment en ontario est ce
que monsieur charest est capable de
faire le plein en ontario et ça peut
jouer dur dans les débats en mai
prochain on va suivre ça merci beaucoup
à vous trois d'avoir été la bonne soirée
bon week-end au revoir avant pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh